it's from Brandon Peterson Sam and
Dave what does coming soon and the last
days mean in the New Testament in light
of the fact that it's been 2,000 years
Jesus says he's coming soon and that
those in the first century um and that
those in the first century in the last
days I think he means uh that those in
the first century are in the last days
so Sam it's been 2,000 been been 2,000
years now we're still waiting Jesus says
he's coming soon Jesus says we're in the
last days and here we are tick tock tick
tock tick tock what's going on here yeah
interestingly uh this poor brother's
been asking the same question the last
three times that we've live streamed and
I've been noticing it now what's even
more interesting is that Peter himself
addresses this very objection in second
Peter chapter 3 yeah he does so instead
of me giving my answer and obviously
Brandon is a Believer Peter wrote second
Peter under inspiration of the holy
spirit so instead of me explaining what
coming soon coming quickly means let's
have Peter explain that for us in second
Peter chapter 3 now David let's just
read the first eight verses 2 Peter 3:8
if you want to read out loud Peter tells
us coming soon coming quickly is not
from our perspective it's from God's
perspective because in that very context
he's going to State quite clearly that a
day to the Lord is like a thousand years
and a thousand years is like a day
meaning that time is
absolutely insignificant or
inconsequential when it comes to God
coming soon to him a thousand years is
like a day so that's soon enough for him
but let's let Peter address it in 2
Peter
3:8 so if you want to read it for us
this is now the second letter that I am
writing to you beloved in both of them I
am stirring up your sincere Mind by way
of reminder that you should remember the
predictions of the Holy prophets and the
Commandment of the Lord and Savior
through your Apostles knowing this first
of all that scoffers will come in the
last day days with scoffing following
their own sinful desires they will say
where is the promise of his coming that
sound familiar you're right they will
say where is the promise of his coming
for ever since the fathers fell asleep
all things are continuing as they were
from the beginning of creation for they
deliberately overlook this fact that the
heavens existed long ago and the earth
was formed out of water and through
Water by the word of God and that by
means of these the world that then
existed was deluged with water and
perished but by the same word the
heavens and earth that now exist are
stored up for fire being kept until the
day of judgment and destruction of the
ungodly but do not overlook this one
fact beloved that with the Lord one day
is as a thousand years and a thousand
years as one day there you go he
answered it isn't it ironic this very
objection is answered by Peter under
inspiration of the holy spirit in second
Peter chapter 3
because then he even prophesied there'll
be scoffers who going to start mocking
people oh come on what when is Jesus
coming man our fathers have have died
it's been 2,000 years you know you're
going to believe that nonsense and then
he explains that to God coming quickly
even if it's 2,000 years and Jesus shows
up it's still quickly to him because a
thousand years is like a day a day is
like a thousand years in other words
time is inconsequential to God for him a
Timeless being who transcends time even
50,000 years is coming quickly from his
perspective so you have to Define these
terms from God's perspective coming
quickly from God's perspective can be a
thousand years from now 2,000 years from
from now because to him it's all a
moment of time so you have to see it
from that perspective now many people
may not like that answer but that's not
my answer I'm simply quoting what Peter
said by inspiration of the holy spirit
so this is the holy spirit's answer
Brandon so hope that helped uh let me
just uh go ahead and read verse 9 too
because I think that also addresses the
is uh verse 9 same chapter the Lord is
not slow to fulfill his promise as some
count slowness right some people
consider that slow hey you waited 2,000
years this is Peter writing a long long
time ago says the Lord is not slow to
fulfill his promise as some count
slowness but is patient toward you not
wishing that any should perish but that
all should reach repentance so he's
sitting here where is he he said he's
going to come back and he's and here
here's Peter saying if he doesn't come
immediately or if he wait it's because
he's patient it's because he's giving
more people time to repent amen and so I
mean just just just think I mean if he
had come in
1994 or 1995 I was in all kinds of
trouble that was in all kinds of trouble
so fortunately he didn't and I had time
to repent and so it's good it's good on
the I mean on the one hand we want
Justice um we want we want the final
judgment when all things are going to be
set right
but on the other hand on the other hand
we want as many people as possible to be
saved so yeah keep that in mind um just
for Qui he said so it can be 100,00
years from now yeah it's up to the Lord
because time is of no consequence to him
so again this is not our answer it's
Peter's answer by inspiration of the
Holy Spirit of the Living God so